we thank you for joining us on this  wednesday afternoon i'm hector mejia  we start today with news from las vegas  mayor carolyn goodman  in a city council meeting today the  mayor revealed that she tested  positive for kovit 19 even though she's  fully vaccinated  she's recovered now but she says she  does not know where she was exposed  i'm out there all the time probably  inappropriately hugging and touching  people all the time  and that's how i choose to operate and  that's how i will continue to choose to  operate  mayor goodman is 82 years old and a  two-time  cancer survivor she reiterated that her  symptoms were mild and encouraged  everyone  to go ahead and get the vaccine